- I invited my neighbor
from NBC's California Live.
A fellow Texan, I love her.
- [Kimberly] Yeeha!
- And American Idol alum. (laughs)
To be here and help us navigate
through this sticky time.
Okay?
- Okay.
- Please welcome, mom on a mission,
Kimberly Caldwell-Harvey.
- Hey!
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] All right!
- I'm so excited!
- So, I'm excited and I'm sad.
- Okay, so you're a mom.
- Yes.
- You get it, right?
Where's my moms?
(audience women cheering)
Yeah, Christi's down there.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Okay, so with Halloween
just around the corner,
So I teamed up with a
really good friend of mine.
Her name is Dr.Daphna Doot.
- Okay.
- She's a pediatrician,
- She sounds astute!
- She's very, very important,
- Yeah, okay.
- She's a pediatrician, she's a master mom
of children's nutrition.
She gave me all this
expertise, that you know,
I didn't know.
So, I decided to share
it with all you guys.
And y'all can do whatever you
wanna do with the information,
I'm not here to judge.
I have all the information and
I literally fed my daughter
donuts for breakfast this morning!
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
- [Kimberly] All right!
- 'Cause, you're
pregnant, and you're like,
I'm gonna eat it!
- I was gonna say, I fed
both of my daughters,
(Kelly laughs)
donuts for breakfast this morning and so
I'm not a really big fan of learning,
I know, mom of the year.
So, I've decided to play a little game,
it's a true or false game.
But it's the Kelly Clarkson Show.
- I love games!
So, it's, yes ma'am, no ma'am!
- I love it!
(audience applause)
- You love it?
- How Texan, I love it.
All right.
- Let's find out if
you're as a bad a parent
as I am, you ready for this?
- I can already...
Yes ma'am (laughs).
- (laughs) Yes Ma'am!
All right, so are you ready
for some master Mom-ments?
Do you like that?
Mom-ments?
- Mom-ments, I like it,
I see what you did there.
- You liked that, that was cute, right?
- [Kelly] I like it!
- We're so, wow!
(Kelly laughs)
We are easily amused.
- I know!
- Sugar is as addictive
as recreational drugs?
- [Audience] Yes ma'am.
- Yes and I think it's
actually more addictive.
And I am actually a walking
example of this (laughs).
- Okay, Kelly Clarkson
and her master mom-ment!
Yes ma'am!
- [Kelly] Yes ma'am!
(audience applause)
Yes ma'am, next.
- So, you're not gonna give
your kids drugs, but
research shows that sugar is
as addictive as cocaine.
- Okay.
- Eating sugary foods
like candy, chocolate
increases chemicals in
your brain called dopamine.
- [Kelly] Dopamine.
- Dopamine, which gives
us the feel-good high.
So, every time that we eat
sugar we have to eat more sugar,
- [Kelly] I know!
- And guess what that's
called, to get the same high?
- My life, what?
- It's called (laughs).
(audience laughs)
It's also called addiction!
- Addiction, totally.
- Addiction, okay, so, I
have a little solution.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- So, this Halloween instead of feeding,
we're all gonna go
trick-or-treating, let's get over it.
Instead of feeding them the entire bucket,
or letting them have it,
my daughter just turned four yesterday,
happy birthday Harlow,
- [Kelly] That's so cool!
(audience applause)
- So, she just turned four,
so she gets four pieces.
Me and Kelly are 21, we
get 21 pieces of candy!
(audience applause)
- Yes, 21, 21!
- Nailed it, nailed it!
- Just like Sailor.
- Yes, on average, children
under 12 consume almost
25 pounds of sugar a year,
yes ma'am or no ma'am?
- [Audience] Yes ma'am.
- What?
That's a lot!
Yes Ma'am.
- Actually, they do not consume
25 pounds of sugar.
- It's more?
- [Kelly] It's more, I
knew it was gonna be--
- It's a no ma'am, they consume almost
50 pounds of sugar a year!
- [Kelly] What?
- [Kimberly] On average,
and that's actually--
- That's basically just like cancer!
- That's more than us.
We only consume, only 46
pounds of sugar a year.
(audience laughs)
Can you believe that?
I know!
- Speak for yourself!
- We're killing it! (laughing)
- All right, try me.
- I'm holding down
relatable, Kim! (laughs)
- Try me!
Okay, here's the great
thing, you guys, I love this.
You can do a good deed this
Halloween and send all of your
leftover candy to Soldiers'
Angels Treats for Troops program
to deployed service members
and veterans and VA hospitals--
- That's cool!
(audience applause)
- Across the country.
- That's really cool!
- Isn't that so awesome?
- Yeah! (audience applause)
- I got all the truths for you girl,
I'm your momma!
- Okay.
- I love it, I love your being
a mom moments, I love it.